hello everyone it's good to see you all
once again and
uh we'll be starting with today's uh
webinar in just a few minutes from now
at the show you time
thank you for joining
and
meanwhile we begin with the webinar it
would be great to hear from you about
your uh educational or research
background what are your interests which
all backgrounds you come from it would
be really interesting to listen to that
so please put in the chat box i'm
looking forward to hear from you thank
you
i would like to welcome those who have
just joined we'll be starting the
session in more uh five minutes from now
at the schedule time
thank you for joining and meanwhile i
begin with the session it would be great
to hear from you about your educational
research background and also your
research address
recording in progress
oh very warm good morning good afternoon
or good evening in whichever part of the
world you are i would like to welcome
you all for today's webinar on getting
started with bioinformatics in python
and r
so as a as biology is saturated with
complex data sets that have to be sorted
explode and looked into anyone handling
data generation analysis or decision
making based on data has to gain some
level of data science skills
the increasing necessity to process big
data and develop algorithms in all
fields of science mean that programming
is becoming an essential skill for
scientists with python or r the language
of choice for the majority of
bioinformaticians
in most biological and biomedical
sciences
you will be expected to run or implement
programs written in python or r and
others
getting started can be hard programming
is like learning a new language
altogether and that's why we offer easy
to follow structured and simple coding
tutorials designed around bioinformatics
challenges
so without any delay let's get started
with bioinformatics
in python and r
before we begin with today's webinar i
would like to introduce us we are a
us-based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible the training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 350 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine the
local program logistics and leverage our
online cleaning resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
over the past several years we have had
the privilege of working with number of
organizations developing a training
program for research-oriented students
faculty and democratizing bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine powder and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
i would like to take the honor of
introducing the founders and the team
members of the company dr alfred tober
comes from a medical background with an
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of inflammation and one of
his major projects is the establishment
of the topper bioinformatics research
center which has been at the core of
what we do
dr unit brodsky is the director of
troubled bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platform is a result of the hard
work by some of the people mentioned
here on the right
julia pannab is an expert by
informatician avitatovsky needs the
development of t violin for platform dr
mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
he has been developing collaborations
with universities as a mentor and
project lead for our mixologic training
and research fellowship
dr raghavendran is an accomplished
computational biologist with an
experience in large scale analysis of
multi-omics data and data science
methods in precision oncology and
protein dna structural bioinformatics
and my name is tanali khari and i'm the
omixlogic community manager i'm
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of
our community that is managed by buying
biotech
all right so now let's highlight some of
the current challenges and limitations
and how we at omixlogic help resolve
this with our training and research
services
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of bioinformatics is currently
facing
to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power the data sets that are analyzed
are usually very large and take immense
amounts of computing power and memory
that many personal computers do not have
also despite being publicly available
data is also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so
similarly analysis pipelines and
programs require coding knowledge that
many biologists do not have
in a university setting students have
the opportunity to learn the background
information of designing and
implementing a bioinformatics project
but do not receive practical hands-on
experience with the full workflow due to
the limitations mentioned previously
similarly the culture faces challenges
with being able to cover a diverse range
of topics if they are specialized in a
certain area of bioinformatics or if
they're unfamiliar with bioinformatics
in general for example
a professor whose research focuses on
oncogene expression might not know much
about metagenomics of sea water
now to overcome these challenges the
omixlogic platform was developed this
program aims to standardize organize and
systematize bioinformatics training in
order to make these analysis usable for
any biologist or clinician
some problems for standardization which
includes materials for these courses are
usually developed in-house taught
sporadically and are rarely updated
organization because the challenge is to
combine several different topics
together the flow and transitions are
needed to be developed
systematization how can you know that
someone is stuck and needs help or
allows someone to run forward
omixlogic uses standardized modules and
interactive sessions beginning with
mastering terminology and concepts to
implementing these concepts with real
data sets in a project based approach
and in order to create a clear path of
skill development omixlogic employs the
bloom's taxonomy levels of learning
this approach starts with the basics
students recall facts and terminology
and are able to repeat and memorize the
material with this base the learning
builds to conceptual knowledge being
able to understand concepts and apply
information to new situations the
students will then be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods
this leads them to the highest level of
learning the ability to design and
create original work
so how do omisogic resources help
advance bioinformatics teaching omix
logic is a portal for practical and
current and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics composed of courses
designed to take you through the
theoretical knowledge omixlogic takes a
combination of training modules data
analysis tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give students a clear path of the
bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omixlogic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large datasets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like r and python or beginning a data
analysis project
so now let's gear up for today's session
first of all you all need to sign up on
the omixlogic learn portal that will
give you the access to the omixlogic
courses which includes various courses
on bioinformatics precision medicine
multi-omics data science that definitely
includes bioinformatics using r and
python that we shall explore more and
learn about and also example projects on
different fields which you could learn
from and replicate for your research
work
so now without any delay let's go to the
portal and make sure that we have signed
up so that we can follow along the
resources that the mentor will be taking
us through today
thank you so much ojasi for putting the
link uh to the omixlogic learn portal in
the chat box
so please click on the link be in the
chat box that will take you to the
learn.omixlogic.com
and once you are there on the portal
please make sure that you have created
an account for yourself signing up and
having an account on the portal is a
free of course so please make sure that
you have an account
i'll just give a quick demo to all of
you
so that you don't face any issue while
you try to do it yourself
let me log out
all right so this is what you will look
at when you click uh in the on the link
in the chat box you need to click on the
login button and create an account for
yourself
i think i have a slow internet
connection
yes
so click on the login button
once you click on the login button you
will get some options either to create
an account for yourself or you can also
uh sign up with any of your social media
accounts that could be google facebook
linkedin etc and uh i have already
signed up so this is what my account
looks like
once you have signed up please uh make
sure that you have an updated profile
it's very important to have an updated
profile which includes a profile picture
your name should be in title case you
can connect your social media accounts
as well and add a brief file about
yourself that could include your
educational research and trust and also
uh with like what what is your
background and what you want to work on
now having a complete profile and also
keeping a track on the profile will help
you
go through your progress throughout the
program
being a part of the program will uh
will give you a badge which you can see
on your profile clicking on this badge
will take you to the program page now i
shall take you all to the program page
and then um
pass on the stage to our mentor to
discuss more about today's program and
what will be covered in each and every
session
so this is the program page for getting
started with bioinformatics nr i'll put
the link in the chat box and also on
this page we have listed down all the
details of each and every session for
the program and i would like to now pass
on the stage to dr raghav to uh take us
through each and every session and also
help us learn what these sessions
will help us learn about
so over to you dr raghav
yes i think you have the permission now
can you share your screen
yeah thank you very much
i was not able to unmute myself
so can you see my screen i'm driving it
it's loading
it's still loading for me can you see my
screen uh yes sir we can see our screen
okay perfect thank you
okay thank you very much hello everybody
and i uh welcome you all to this online
session to learn more about the programs
uh about getting started with
bioinformatics in r and then python so
in this program generally we will
discuss about
how data-driven research is in life
sciences and and different opportunities
that come with analyzing or
understanding high throughput
technologies and the data associated
with high troop technologies and
computational methods various
computation methods that is used for
analysis annotation of such detailed
data in
leading industrial and research
applications so we will
discuss about various data types
different analytical and statistical
methods used for
analyzing and understanding the data and
the patterns in the data and also
to um
and the impact of such analysis on
healthcare environmental sciences public
health and agriculture etc etc so today
let's learn more about the program uh
about uh
the necessary tools that is required for
performing these analysis methods
so i am raghavendran a bioinformatics
mentor from pine biotech and i will be
one of your mentors throughout your
journey uh in this in this field of
bioinformatics and with comics logics so
as sonalika mentioned the goal of our
mixed logics program is to provide you
enough training in bioinformatics and to
enable you independent uh to perform
independent research guided by mentors
and by other peer examples we also
facilitate developing a growing
community with a sharing passion for
data-driven research and appreciation
for uh citizen sciences
so in these programs that you see and
the associated learning resources you
will
it's running
wait a second it's yeah
you will see broad applications of next
generation sequencing and you will see
applications of how bio statistics and
how tools for uh some tools for these
omics data analysis are used uh in the
environment of uh r and in python so the
learning resources resources will be
focused on the logic and the application
of
data science methods for biomedical data
in programming environment like r and
also in python so uh
this will also provide you technical
in-depth review of coding with these
languages and
this will also help you in
with the help of practical assignments
you will be learning about how the logic
of bioinformatics and see how these
methods can be used to study biology in
general
so in in conclusion you will also be
able to plan how to take what you have
learned so far and apply it to an
independent research project using tools
methods we cover uh in the program
so we will review generally the concepts
behind common challenges in biomedical
data analysis that is finding signal in
noisy data sets and to find biological
explanation for the results we will also
see challenges and applications uh
challenges and opportunities to use
general statistical methods and advanced
statistical methods to find complex
molecular characteristics and patterns
that can be associated with the
neurotypical conditions and biological
conditions that we can interpret
so
at the basis of
this
there is so much interest in data
science from biology and from medical
community
these days and the researchers from both
the fields are gen and researchers from
bioinformatics and biology
field are generating massive amounts of
data and as any field that has huge
amounts of data people are interested in
what this data can offer so people like
people from data science methods can
can actually
perform this analysis purely from data
science perspective and understand the
patterns from the data
so
this processes of
analyzing this data and filtering these
large data sets and produce meaningful
biological and medical insights by
application of statistical and machine
learning models and methods are actually
yeah are actually driving these results
and this research further so uh
in order to be able to
succeed in this in this research or in
this
in the research of bioinformatics you
need not be expert in everything but you
should at least have some practical
experience in
in
encoding and in domain specific data
processing and in
general uh filtering and data
transformation techniques and in
application of
statistical uh basic statistical and
advanced statistical methods and machine
learning methods so you should be able
to uh understand
several different methodologies used to
analyze
big data or big or mixed data so
being able to write code or being able
to understand the code that is written
by others is is one of the one of the
most um
prerequisites to proceed further and
understand develop a deeper
understanding in bioinformatics and and
data science methods what we get a
analysis so um
by the end of this program we will
enable you to understand
different methodologies that are
discussed in in the publication and to
be able to
use understand codes that are available
and with the associated uh publications
and and also uh being able to
generate or being able to develop your
own code for
for the analysis of
next generation sequencing data
so this field as we know has developed
tremendously in the last several decades
transforming life sciences and enabling
biomedical research
so as a result we have many new
discoveries and uh most of these
discoveries uh are the result of
generation generation of large amounts
of comics data
that includes genomics data genomics
data epigenomics and different comics
data from different
molecules that characterize the cells of
organisms so many of these omics data
can be generated using next generation
sequencing methods or which is also
known as high throughput sequencing
numbers the data here um show a detailed
information about genomic variants about
the patterns of the gene or patterns of
the gene expression isoform expression
and different
um molecular characteristics of the cell
that can be associated with the
phenotypical or biological state of the
cell that we are studying
so
in order to explore further with the
with um
with the programming environment we will
take variety of the such examples excuse
me my computer is not responding yeah we
will take variety of research
examples and and learn about the logic
behind each steps and uh
each of these types of using our mixed
data or big data to study uh cancer
tissue biology and microbiome for
example in um in
in some of the project and
associated project examples that we are
going to discuss with in this program
so
basically
as a as we had
discussed already there is a tremendous
amount of our mix data that has been
generated generated but most of these
generated methods of generated data has
been is is unstructured so one of the
challenges of converting or one of the
challenges of
applying different machine learning
methods and machine learning different
data science methods and the analytical
methods is to convert these unstructured
data into structured data so
for to enable this uh this conversion of
to enable generation of the structured
data from these unstructured data
uh we also have several other programs
and several other uh
courses that deals with how uh
structured data can be generated from
genomics data and social genomics data
transcriptomics data and etc etc so once
you have structured data and and
we can use uh a programming environment
or coding environment like
python to uh understand or to um
getting started with the
excuse me
getting started with with understanding
the logic or coding skills that you need
to
try and
learn about the patterns that are
that that are buried deep into the data
so we can uh go over this in in in the
associated lessons and most of the
lessons and resources are structured in
uh in these six
uh structured uh structure uh um
ladder so first we have to understand
the problem of what we are going to deal
with and then we learn the code so we
will go over this in uh
by uh by exploring some of the lessons
and
go over this step by step but in general
each of these lessons are structured as
this so we we will just we will make you
familiarize with the problem or the
statement or the aim of the lesson
and then we will help you in
understanding or in learning the code
that is necessary to perform these
analysis
and then we will also help you to
learn
key
parts or key syntax elements of the code
so that you can modify the output or you
can modify the method that will suit or
that will make you or enable you to uh
appreciate the kind of analysis that is
performed on the structured data
and then we will also have a
different try to try it out yourself uh
section where we uh give you a code
block with uh missing syntaxes or with
incomplete uh codes so uh from from the
learning that you had um
acquired from learn the code section you
can apply it to these areas and to these
uh code blocks and then successfully run
the code and thereby enabling a deeper
understanding of this coding and then
this also
helps you to modify some of the aspects
of the code and then get
more clearer picture or give a practical
hands-on experience of understanding the
code and then in the end we also give
you uh
a much more detailed and much more
elaborate assignment where you will you
that you are expected to
not only to complete the syntaxes but
modify few of the syntaxes and apply it
to a different dataset for example or
apply it using a different methodology
ah so that you can gain an appreciation
for the
code code lessons that you have learned
so far so this is a structure for both r
and python and
again my depth
so ah this has several
topics and this linked with uh
and is also linked with example data
sets using um
example data sets that are
properly i mean that are carefully
curated um for um
curated from various research domains
like cancer or infectious diseases and
etcetera etcetera so yeah
so we also provide a comprehensive
experience in uh
in in an introduction to data science or
machine learning methods in in r and
python using uh r and python and there
are so you will also
enjoy
uh getting introduced to different
machine learning tools and statistical
analysis tools and how
you can apply that to various omics
logics various omics data so to
understand
the patterns and to understand the
general
biology behind the data
so
each of this lesson as i mentioned comes
with a practice console and you can
use it right in the browser so you don't
have to go out of the browser
environment to practice these
codes that you are that we have learned
so far um so
first
as i mentioned in learn the code section
you will be learning about the logic the
syntax and
here in this practice console you can
test your understanding with hands-on
experiences
and hands-on exercises so as this
video just mentions you just complete
this instant taxes and then
click run to generate the output and to
verify that you have
successfully completed the challenge so
that
you can gain a deeper understanding of
the code that is
so in this in the
in the next section breakdown you'll
also learn about the objective and and
strategy for any a given method and then
you will also see
and you'll also
see how the code or how to code
code for a solution or code for for a
problem by learning the syntax and
testing your understanding with
assignment and coding languages so in
the end of a python lesson for example
uh you will be given or given access to
a a collab notebook or an interactive
notebook which you can modify or which
you can
uh used to uh uh used to
analyze for for a different data set or
for modified data set or for modified
methodology so that you not only uh
run or not only uh try to run what was
given in the lesson but also you can
expand your understanding in in this
coding
environment in general
so each of these
collab notebook will also be
supplemented supplementary will also be
in will also include uh assignments and
these assignments can as i mentioned um
can be comprised of uh
modification of the methods or uh
applying this methods of different types
of methods to
different data sets or same data set
comparison of the uh
comparing the output and gaining some
biological insights and you can submit
these assignments to us
by completing this uh this um
assignment uh
given at the end of the collaborations
so in the end generally you will be able
to take the structured data that you
generate from uh from a sequence of
sequence
of analysis pipelines to understand uh
to apply to different areas of
biomedical research like uh
clinical like uh phenotypic and other
different areas of environmental
research so as as i mentioned we will uh
um
we will start from very basic uh
like um
how to understand and how to load uh
how to load um a file in an environment
like r and python
and
we will slowly build up the complexity
of your
programming
requirements or programming knowledge
and then in the end we will help you to
run
necessary statistical analysis necessary
exploratory analysis and the different
statistical analysis so that you can
discover patterns in real data sets that
are used in the publications and using
the researchers to study and understand
molecular phenomena or biological
phenomena at different levels
so uh
yeah this we already spoke about these
this includes uh
basic coding challenges like
loading data from uh from your computer
that is in different format like in
comma separated format or on txt format
or or even excel sources and you have to
place these loaded
data into different data structures and
you will gain a much more
detailed
understanding of what these data
structures and how
and what are the different structures
that we are going to use to analyze on
its data so this you can perform in both
in r and python and we have a parallel
uh
coding um lessons and program running
for both
rn python and um
as i mentioned uh all of these coding
lessons are actually organized uh with
with plenty of comments and with plenty
of descriptions so that each and every
part of the syntax is actually discussed
so in the end at
the culminating end of this program you
will be
explained or you will be given access to
uh access to model projects and example
projects where we uh take the curated
data set or where we take the data set
that is used in publications like this
and curate this data set to apply uh
either this similar
statistical methods or different data
science methods ah that can be applied
to the
curated data and then the patterns
within this data can be
understood or can be
studied to relate to phenotypical
characteristics like drug response or
like
like
different
tumor stages or different patient
stratification etc etc so this is not
the only example projects that we will
be discussing and by gaining access to
the
learner mixed logic platform you will
also gain access to different example
projects that we have generated or we
have
we have
developed for your deeper understanding
of
bioinformatics methods from
different omics data types so let's
quickly uh
get or go to uh
comics logics platform and
understand how
once it starts responding yeah
understand how these coding sessions are
actually organized
i hope you can see my screen and
i'm not getting any confirmation can
sanika can you confirm that you can see
my stream yes sir we can see your screen
okay uh
so this is a program page for getting
started with bio mathematics in python
and uh you can access all the resources
or you can access the timetable of when
each and every session is actually
planned by uh scrolling through the
pages
and in each of these and each and every
one of these sessions you will have
coding lessons or associated resources
uh that are to be covered or that are to
be
uh
in order for you to progress to the next
uh stage so it will be uh yeah you can
click and uh
go over these resources uh let's uh
for example start with uh
let's start with
r
uh
and
[Music]
so one of the associated lessons in in
the beginning of beginning section of
in the starting uh session in the first
session is uh introduction to r or how
to
install and how to get r working in your
computer and how to get python working
in your computer so uh this is just uh
as i mentioned uh a brief overview of
how to get this done but there are
plenty of other resources to um help you
with how to set up a r and different
python environment so this
is so once you have successfully
installed r so one of the challenges
that everybody faces uh when when they
get introduced to a programming
environment or a coding environment is
how to
load a file into this programming and
beyond so we start with that with some
example codes or how to import or how to
view a text file into our
environment so
look at this
detailed explanation where each and
every part of each and every aspect of
each and every portion of the syntax is
um explained or is uh discussed very uh
in a in a detailed path so uh you
obviously need some uh object or some um
data variable to place the uh table uh
read uh
place the text file that you are reading
into
so um that that we discuss and we use
what is a function that is used
generally to read the file and what is
what are the
different
components that is
absolutely necessary for this function
to
execute properly and essentially so uh
after this as i mentioned you have to
load in the data and then put it in some
put it in some obser objects so there
are several different uh
objects that are available uh depending
upon your programming language and and
most general ones are either using a
data frame or a vector or a matrix etc
so you can go over these to understand
what each and every one of them
me or
how we how that is defined in the
context of biological data or in the
context of comics data so we also give
you option to not only read one type of
file but a different type of file and
once you have read in file you can
perform something like
an exploratory analysis to understand
the distribution of the data across
different samples
so we start with very basic level like
without any modification what happens if
you just type the function and then we
slowly build up
in the complexity
by increasing
the
necessary components that will take
something like this
plot which is
which is absolutely beginner level to
something like
this plot
which gives you more information and
also which looks very
pretty that you can use it for
publication and etcetera etcetera
so in a learn the code section this is
where you will
practice all the necessary or all the
knowledge that you have acquired from
learn the code etc so we give you a a
brief uh overview of what is necessary
or what is uh required from
um
for you to complete this challenge and
we say okay um you can import in your
text file or you can use this text file
link to use below
and
you can right click and copy the link
cutter so we will do that
right click and copy the link address so
here we have deleted some parts or some
of some portions of the code and we need
to um complete those parts to run this
specific
code
so let's yeah so uh in load the data if
you had understood that so if you had
gone through uh
the code you will know that this is
where you have to paste the
link and
go through go over this and
try to run it so if you just try to run
it
a
a response console window will open and
it will tell you uh
at the um
uh it will tell you
the output that is
generated but
the
the aim of this specific coding lesson
is not complete yet and how do we know
that so on successful completion you
will get a window that tells you a
confirmation that tells you code is run
and code is complete and you have
successfully completed the code and
answer is correct so this tells we have
to check the dimension of the data which
we did not complete in the incomplete
syntax which we will do now and we can
use to either uh refresh or we reload
the code area if you have gone too far
in trying to uh in the modification and
you can actually
clear this response console so we will
clear the response console but clearing
response console will not clear what
modifications that we have done in the
coding section and then we'll run the
code
and this is a confirmation that you will
get
yes
it actually comes down there but yeah i
cannot see it so you have run the code
and successfully run the code and your
task is complete so you can
starting from absolute basic level like
like one or two lines of code and then
you can start increasing the complexity
of the code here
like what is given here we can also go
over this so we box plot and change the
direction of the access legends and we
can just type run this
and to know
it says something is missing so there is
no default value something is missing so
we will complete that
copy the missing part and run it
and you can generate
the
uh generate a graph or pictorial output
with this uh coding environment also
so you can go ahead and then complete
all the uh
all the necessary all the time to
yourself
sections if you are stuck or if you do
not know how to complete this so
all of these challenges that that are
included in the try it yourself section
has been taken from learn the code area
or learn the example code or where we
are
explaining you how to
understand different
parts of this code so if you are stuck
you can refer to this code and then come
back
and complete the
ah
complete the try it yourself section so
once you have understood and developed a
better understanding of
how to execute these r codes and how to
successfully complete some smaller
assignments then we have a
bigger assignment where we give you a
space to complete this assignment so uh
so yeah you can check uh yeah um
complete this assignment by uh
going through the learning learn
session and then take several
parts of the core and then
paste it here and complete your section
so somebody has raised their hands yes
can you please paste your question in
the chat
okay i believe proper screen is not
i just see pca website not the one okay
i will stop share
which pca website you are
looking at
okay i will share it again
let's see
oh
sorry
okay
uh say a screen was properly visible to
us maybe it could be
[Music]
thank you thank you
okay thank you thank you for the
compliment
so this is how for example an
introductory uh
coding lessons are organized in um
in in learner mixed logic platform and
we can also go through some some python
lessons
like yeah
if you click on the data visualization
associated resources
that is to be completed after the first
session so you will get uh much more uh
information or much more uh
examples of a lot of examples on how to
visualize your data uh using several
different uh plotting methods so again
this also follows the same structure so
uh we have to understand um the aim of
what is the analysis that we are aiming
to complete and uh
we have to learn the code here so um
so this is uh broken down we will start
by
understanding or we will start by
loading up necessary libraries and
[Music]
different packages that is required for
the analysis and we will go by one by
one perform this analysis and ah
you can practice the code
again
just like how
the practice of code section has been
given for r and there is a slight
difference in how you are going to
import or how you are going to use the
file uh but a detailed explanation of
how to drop a file like uh for uh um for
giving the uh
giving the console access to your file
has been explained also so you can go
over that and
complete the
python lessons also
so let's go back to the presentation and
uh yeah and cover
and go over the uh syllabus or go over
the curriculum that is uh supposed to be
or that is plan uh two to be covered
in the upcoming program for
introduction to bioinformatics analysis
in our pipe
so if you have any questions until now
please feel free to type in the chat box
i'm following the chat box so let's
get that
once i
get this
can you see my screen
i think it's still not yet
yeah it's still loading for me
i think this should work
i think i have to stop sharing start
sharing one more time
okay
i think and now i get confirmation that
you can see me screaming
we can see your screen okay perfect
thank you very much so let's go over the
curriculum what is planned for uh
plan for getting started with uh
bioinformatics in python and and then
also in r
uh so you will start by uh uh by getting
an introduction to big data in
bioinformatics like uh um
you will get an introduction to how to
use the platform and how to use
different sections of the platform like
uh you will start with absolute basics
like um how can uh like a couple of
links to install python in your computer
for example or what is a
general ide or uh in
interactive development environment or
we
that you can use um
to
use along with the python
so that you can
code
in a more user-friendly manner
and
and you will also learn how to for
example
perform couple of
analysis like couple of exploratory
analysis like as i men as i had
given an introduction to like a box plot
or like a scatter plot etcetera etcetera
in the first
session and then we will slowly start
working uh towards increasing the
complexity of of um
understanding how you can use python to
load biological data like uh the load
dna sequence data and how how you can
for example
convert the dna sequence into rna
sequence or dnac concentric protein
sequence or how we can get
um
display or how you can make a multiple
sequence alignment display
using
python and how you can perform for
example
a very basic
sequence comparison analysis using two
different
dna strings so
this will not only give you some of the
necessary
functions that you will
need to work with python for
bioinformatics data but it will also
give you how or how generally
how python is
used and what are the different tools in
python is and that are used for
bioinformatics analysis for dna sequence
analysis and etcetera
so you will again
then proceed towards
exploratory analysis where you can
make changes to the data to the
organization of the data that is data
wrangling and you can pre-process the
data which is absolutely necessary
for
for different statistical analysis
and you can perform exploratory analysis
you can perform
visualization of
different exploratory analysis and
using
log transform data for example or using
combined pooled data or using a subset
of your data set so all of these methods
will come under data wrangling and
visualization and then we will also
help you uh generate or understand
different uh
dimensionality reduction uh tools like
uh plots like using principle component
analysis or um
or psne or umap etc can be used to
visualize the
pattern that that is present in your
data
so um so this will be your third session
where you will straight away start
working with uh with the structured data
uh to understand the pattern to
generally understand the pattern uh that
underlies or that is hidden inside the
data
and then you can go one step higher or
one step uh more complex by trying to
compare different subsets or different
samples sets of the data that you have
or structure data that you have so these
comparisons can be performed by
um
by by
with the use of uh
t test or uh
differential gene expression analysis or
different
clustering or unsupervised
machine learning methods like clustering
and
hierarchical clustering and k means
clustering and all of these will
help you
differentiate multiple sample types for
example in the data or multiple
data types or different phenotypical
types that are
reflected in the distribution of the
data that we are analyzing this data can
be
i mean for example uh transcriptomics
data uh this data can be meta genomics
data and etc uh different different
types of data will also be
discussed and what we are going to gain
from these different types of data
and what we are going to understand from
analyzing these different types of data
will also be discussed so um and you can
expand your
knowledge of bioinformatics knowledge in
python to apply that to various other
types of data and
so then we will we will then um
go or we will then uh
go to or
learn about machine learning tools like
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning tools and algorithms that are
generally used for
biological data or bio
big data mixed data and
you will also be
introduced to or you'll also be
explained on
different parameters and settings that
are that one needs that one needs to
account for when you are using different
supervised and unsupervised algorithms
like
um how you can set up for supervised
algorithm supervised machine learning
analysis and how what you can actually
gain uh uh from uh from the output of
supervised and unsupervised analysis and
how you can
for example um
evaluate the performances of
unsupervised machine learning methods
and supervised machine learning methods
etc that you can uh
that will also be discussed and you will
also be um
introduced to a few uh a couple of
introductions to uh predictive models
using deep learning methods also so you
can also use dimensionality reduction uh
with deep learning and we will also
share you some coding lessons that will
help you or get that will give a brief
introduction to
deep learning methods and how it can be
applied to
big data
big
data
that is generated from high throughput
so uh
in the end of this
bioinformatic interactive bioinformatics
in python
you will also be introduced to different
uh project
uh
that uses or
that uses
python environment for
detailed downstream analysis like uh in
meta genomics or in
machine learning so you will be
introduced to uh these example projects
like what was the original aim
that was
that the
research article intended to perform
with the data and uh what is a part of
the data that we are considering and
what what is the hypothesis that we are
setting up and what is the
different methods that we are going to
employ to
verify or to understand the patterns
within the data and
on different steps and different
analysis tools that is necessary to
perform these analysis and
once this analysis is performed and how
you can relate the characteristics and
how you can implicate uh
biological understanding from the
results that you have obtained from
performing these analysis
so um
this uh yeah that will conclude our um
python courses and in parallel we will
also have access to getting started with
uh bioinformatics in r so those who are
familiar and those who are
comfortable with python as a coding
environment can opt for python course
and those works
comfortable with r can opt for our
courses so again you will
get get an introduction to how you are
going to access big data
in in our environment and um
like um basic um
understanding of what is the environment
in in our studio or our coding
environment and what are the different
different
tools and different
operators and different uh
symbols that we need to understand from
our uh from a coding point of view it is
uh
it is little bit easier to understand a
python code than to understand an r code
but
a tremendous support and excellent
visual
visualization platforms for r actually
makes
are one of the r and python together
right but are slightly uh more used
platform for
bioinformatics data analysis but python
is also catching up
in that aspect so we will again start
with loading data into r and how
you can load the data visualize the data
for example study the structures of the
data summarize the data so
you can learn a lot about the data just
by
making or printing out first few lines
of the data so all of these
will be uh covered in the first session
so in the second session again we are
going to introduce two working with uh
nucleotide or dna sequences in r in an
aim for you to understand how to perform
or how to use a comparative
sequence comparative method comparison
methods using r as a tool so that you
can generate an appreciation for
how to
strings or how to dna sequences are
compared and what are we
understanding by comparing uh two dna
sequences or multiple more than two dna
sequences and etcetera etcetera and you
will also have
some introduction to um visualization
and exploration exploratory analysis
that will explore uh patterns in the
data again you can
for example visualize the data in the
form of heat map or in the form of a
compiled um
scatter plot or in
in in box plot as i actually as as we
went through and etc
so um
you will again
uh yeah this is advanced visualization
in in r where you can not only employ
basic rs functions to
visualize the data you can also use
advanced visualization methods using
dedicated packages like gg plot or gg45
uh so that the output that you are
getting is is of publication quality and
this of uh
research sharing the quality so
you will also be introduced again to
different dimensionality reduction
techniques and how we can use these
principal component analysis and other
dimensionality reflection techniques to
explore more about the data to
understand patterns in the data and to
identify outliers that that could uh
actually
hinder our downstream analysis and
etcetera you can learn a lot from these
exploratory analysis and preprocessing
of the
data
and then you can proceed uh further by
by
employing the data into different
statistical analysis again you can
perform
factor regression analysis or
differential gene expression analysis in
the in the event of transcriptomics data
to understand ah gene expression
patterns that are different in
for example in cells in an altered state
or in a disease state compared to cells
that are in normal condition
and um
yeah
and we will again proceed to uh
different
machine learning
methods like supervised and unsupervised
analysis and how you can
prepare the data for these analysis
methods and and
what are the different parameters that
one needs to keep in mind for
employing these methods to
biological data because that that
actually changes
biological data is slightly little bit
different from um
normal like economics data and other
internet of things data that is used
generally more used for
machine learning analysis and artificial
intelligence and data science methods
analysis and what are the
key um
parameter settings and assumptions that
we need to
understand and that that we need to
consider
while i'm employing these methods for
big data or on external data
we can again
compare
or we can evaluate the
performances of unsupervised and
supervised machine learning models using
different
evaluation metrics
and
comparative visualization
of
unsupervised analysis by comparing
the patterns that it
discovers with the patterns that is
already uh with the different
phenotypical characters that that is
associated with the data set
so this again uh this program will
conclude uh
with a very uh detailed an example a
research project on um
applying for example r and
different libraries of our for
uh understanding metagenomics data
analysis in the context of a role of
high fat diet on obesity so you will be
introduced to uh
what is the data about and how did we
get this structured data and what is the
intended analysis and what is the
hypothesis
or what are we expecting to find what is
the aim of this analysis
in this project and then you will also
be introduced to different packages and
different
data formats and
how to use different these packages and
what are the considerations that you
have to consider while performing this
analysis
and
in the end you can
actually um
you will have a lot of discussions on
what are the biological implications of
the these different analysis methods and
the results that it produces and how
that
will and how that relates to the actual
finding of the paper and
generic understanding of how meta
genomics analysis uh for such a
such a
question or such a biological research
question
works and uh
yeah uh you will also be given
uh access to a collab notebook that will
that will have a collection of all these
codes to perform these analysis and
you can yeah you can use these notebooks
for
for for the assignments that we are
sharing and for uh comparing different
methodologies or comparing different
data sets that we can
take from
publicly available resources for
big data or big
data
so yeah that will uh conclude today's
session or my uh
my session on
um
on introducing you to the curriculum of
getting started with bioinformatics in r
in python and i'll be happy to take some
questions if you have and
i take
this opportunity to thank and i look
forward to meet
all of you in the program and uh
i hand over the podium now to sonalika
by the way
thank you so much dr raghav for the
detailed explanation of each and every
session that would be covered in the
getting started with the bioinformatics
and python and our programs and now if
there are any questions please put them
in the chat box so that we can take them
in the meantime let me share my screen
yes you can uh put your question in the
chat box
i can see rk has raised his hand you
want to ask something
uh hello there am i audible
yes you are uh yeah i just wanted to
know that uh what is actually the
like the difference between like uh the
courses that you offer on the website
like the basic starter and those
the paid ones and like this program that
we are going to attend
can you just brief me about that
yes definitely i can all right so uh
you can see my screen right yeah
so what is the difference uh in a
program and the coursework that is up
there so what happens in the starter
subscription with which the users get
the access to the various courses that
are up there on the portal you get the
access to the coursework but what do you
not get is the uh mint guidance right so
you are supposed to go through these
resources at your own pace all by
yourself and when you become a part of
an online mentor guided training program
itself that we have uh sessions where
you can take your questions from the
mentors and
we'll be having live sessions or the
recorded sessions where the mentor will
be taking you through the code
themselves and um help you
understand the code blocks and various
things like
working with your data set processing
normalization visualization etc etc and
help you clarify your questions
that's it and uh the
so this major difference actually plays
a very big role because so when users
work with their code blog they get stuck
and having a mental guidance helps them
proceed forward
does that make sense is it clear to you
i don't know i mean sorry you you have a
very short form
all right
and monday is asking how can we download
the r and python
okay so uh
mantra i'll just come back to back to
your question uh monday the first thing
is that we'll be yes taking you
definitely through how to install rn
python and to understand that you can
simply go through the very first lessons
of rn python courseworks
the first lesson
is free and it will help you
go through
this lesson and install
rstudio right
go to this first lesson you have all the
details on how you have to download the
r
rstudio
and here it is installation of our this
will help you
and for python you can work with jupyter
notebooks it's not important that you
really have to download it and also to
mention here though dr raghav has
already mentioned but still i mentioned
it once again that the best thing about
the portal is that when you have to
learn about the syntax of
doing various things with your data set
it's that you can go through the code
block here and then practice it here in
the console itself you need not download
our studio for the practice part but yes
when you're working on a project and
have your own date on own data set it's
definitely easy to have the our studio
and then work with it
uh okay
now coming to mahindra's
question
i would like dr raghav to actually
answer this question dr raghav i'll put
it in your personal chat mahindra is
asking
uh
how can
i expect higher package and career
growth after taking this particular
program
when uh dr raghav would
uh you will i mean yeah
you will learn uh
coding first if you are if you have some
uh if you have introduction to coding
and if you have um
the logic uh behind
different analysis methods and can
understood these methods and we will
introduce you to uh different tools that
are necessary to perform or mix data
analysis in in r or python so uh first
you will have uh
you'll have
developed a skill set for uh omics data
analysis in r let's say and uh not only
uh like loading the data and then just
opening it up but uh
like performing the necessary analysis
that will culminate into a research
paper and um
by discussing different uh example
projects we will make you understand uh
the methodologies that are usually
discussed when uh in bioinformatics
projects and bioinformatics research
papers or that
that um
analyzes big on its data so once you
have uh acquired uh the necessary uh
understanding to uh for example
[Music]
to understand different methods that are
used in research papers or for example
different
codes that are actually available a lot
in the support groups and you can take
those codes understand
different parts of the code just like
learning the code process and then
modify it and tweak it so that you can
perform that analysis for your dataset
so you have essentially
started with
exploring r as a tool to uh
using rs and analysis methods and
different methods to uh perform analysis
for yourself so that is a skill
development and
this will actually help you
in
in for example
gaining a domain knowledge in
bioinformatics like once you have
acquired this skill and then after going
through several
research papers that does similar
bioinformatics analysis then you have
you will be developing a deeper
understanding in the domain itself in
how such analysis methods can new
can help you
ask
relevant questions and answer relevant
questions with these analysis methods so
that okay you have eight years of
experience in u.s health care and how
can i expect higher packaging
you can add one more skew to your uh
level and then with your experience then
your experience in uh
in your
in in
introduction or getting familiarized to
different
data types for example you can apply or
take these
methods to
for different analysis for application
of
machine learning and other tools
um healthcare data so that you can get a
deeper understanding
of
the patterns in the healthcare data so
application of machine learning and ai
tools to healthcare data is is really
hot now and how you can integrate
these different and health informatics
data with big data big data
bioinformatics is is also very
rapidly developing uh
field so uh i think uh
yeah you can gain a lot from these uh
programs and and
um
that will
really be a good addition to your
yeah to your experience
and
yeah and to your general
expanding of your horizons in the
bioinformatics analysis of the knowledge
of
bioinformatics data analysis or big data
bioinformatics
so hope i think i have
answered part of your queries and
convinced you that
you will gain a lot more knowledge by
getting through or by
signing up for this package
any other questions thank you so much
sir
yes thank you so much and uh myndra is
asking about uh placements after
completion of the course and paid
internship paid internships yes we can
definitely guide you about the same
after completing the course work but
it's just uh
like a week 15 days long program so uh
definitely after like just a 15 days
long program what you can expect is um
maybe a job position with the required
skill set that we can uh tell you about
so yes after the program we'll
definitely have a session where we can
discuss about various opportunities that
you can
leverage after getting some good
hands-on with r or python whichever
course or program you pick
yes so now it's time that i take you all
through the registration part of this
particular program so here is the
program page for getting started with r
and uh once you're here on the program
page if you scroll uh down
you will be able to look at the schedule
so this schedule
that dr raghav discussed with us it's
mentioned here on which state which
particular topic would be covered and
what all coding lessons are you supposed
to go through as a part of each and
every session has been mentioned as well
and you can go through this particular
uh page to get more insights about the
schedule and then if you scroll uh below
you'll
be able to look at three different
subscription levels beginner
intermediate and advanced and you you
can pick the level that um works the
best for you
and uh those who are in
different countries and not us maybe you
can convert it to your own currency by
multiplying with the conversion and then
look at the amount right
all right so now what are these
different subscription levels all about
in the beginner subscription level you
will get the access to such sessions
like the way we just had today a group
session that the mentor uh today the
mentor did just explain about the
program what will we cover what it is
all about otherwise we'll be having the
uh the topics covered for each and every
session you know in in the intermediate
subscription level you will get um an
access to also the one-on-one mentor
support along with these group sessions
that we would be having and in the
advanced level you will get some extra
time to work with the mentor to frame a
research question or have a research
proposal in hand it could help you if if
it's a requirement for you to submit a
proposal maybe for your higher studies
or your next
job position right or you want to get
started with a research project but you
are not sure uh what like what exactly
you should be working on so you will get
this extra time to work on your research
proposal and get started with the
research project right so that is the
the difference the main difference
between these three different
subscription levels pick the one that
works the best for you
and once you have uh subscribed to this
program page after it you will be able
to find all the session recordings here
on the page itself now let's say you
were not able to attend a particular
session so you can get back to to this
program page and just go through the
recording and take your questions in the
slack channel so each and every
participant of the program
gets a chance to become a part of our uh
bioinformatics community and we have
specific assigned groups for each and
every program in our slack community so
you join the slack group and you take
your questions from the mentors in the
group itself after watching the
recording and uh that will help you out
and also before each and every session
you want the zoom link we'll mail you
the zoom link as well
and if our mail goes to your promotions
box let's see first of all don't forget
it to um
just shift it to your main primary inbox
otherwise you can also look at the zoom
link here uh under each and every
session as well
and along with this particular program
you will get the access to work on um
two of the main courseworks with r and
that is by info and r and bio ml
uh
r
and talking about the python pro
program page now
um daniel you can't find the find that
page which page this page it's in the
chat
if you click on it you'll be able to
open it
all right
now the second uh program getting
started with buying smarties in python
so uh let me
send the link of this page in the chat
as well i'll also uh mail the links of
these pages to everyone and also i'll
tell you how you can go to these pages
directly from the portal
okay so uh the same thing if you scroll
down you'll be able to look at the
session details in here on which all
dates
like what exactly are we going to cover
the same thing that you'll be able to
also find the zoom links here before
each and every session and a recording
after each and every session
and if you scroll down the subscription
levels have been uh defined here as well
for the program pick the one that works
best for you i've already explained the
difference between the subscription
levels uh if there is any doubt in it
please you can put in the chat box and
i'm here to answer your question
and in the python program you will get
the access to bioinfo and python uh
coursework and by ml using python all
right
now just to
uh tell you how you can go through these
particular
programs if you lose track of the links
just go to learn.mixologic.com
uh portal and then click on the programs
tab
here you can simply
type r
and this is the page that you want to go
to
and
pick your subscription
all right
and after you take your subscription you
want to follow the recordings and also
the resources again the same thing go to
the programs just type in our python and
here is your page
okay
that was about uh program page
registration recording how we
communicate and what resources you will
get the access to
any other questions if there are any
questions please put them in the chat
all right so there are no questions now
uh i'll just quickly drop our main
address and you can reach out to us for
any questions that you might have thank
you so much spash for putting in the
main address in the chat box please make
sure that you uh add this main address
in your address book uh so that
no like none of the means drop in your
promotions box
and with that we are good to end today's
session and spash has shared with us the
calling number for the indian contact if
you want to be a part of the program you
can reach out to her and she'll be able
to help you uh get along with the
program also one of the
participants in the webinar today ask
for the scholarship form so i will put
the scholarship form in the chat also
you can reach out to sparsh again on the
same mail id
and she'll be able to help you proceed
with your application forward
and with that we are good to end today's
session
and we'll meet you soon on may 3rd and
get you started with r and python thank
you everyone for joining have a very
nice day